a diver in Hawaii was treated to a  mesmerizing sight when he spotted an  octopus changing color spotted at Ava  pinnacles Oahu Hawaii  the octopus almost appears to light up  with color in case you didn't know an  octopus uses camouflage as its first  line of defense against predators the  invertebrate uses a network of pigment  cells and muscles to change color and it  makes it so it instantly blends in with  its surroundings this defensive tactic  enables the octopus to evade predators  such as sharks and dolphins octopuses  are often found in warm tropical and  also temperate waters around the world  [Music]  while most octopus species are smaller  some can grow to more than a hundred  pounds that is enormous  [Music]  in addition to camouflage an octopus  also uses ink as a defensive and  offensive tool  [Music]  [Music]  you